warum ist die bar weinort mallorca
niedergebrannt warum ist eine
zigarettenkippe ursache dafür stimmt das
wirklich und hat wirklich einer der 13
deutschen kegelbrüder aus münster diese
zigarettenkippe in die bar eingeworfen
und wenn ja wer von denen es scheint
unmöglich all diese fragen zweifelsfrei
zu klären aber die spanischen ermittler
die haben jetzt erste antworten
gefundene angeblich bild liegt exklusiv
der polizeibericht vor
jetzt haben es die kegelbrüder aus
münster schwarz auf weiß die spanische
kriminalpolizei hält eine
zigarettenkippe für den auslöser des
verheerenden feuers vom 20 mai 2022 am
ballermann aber es gibt keine indizien
wer die kippe geworfen hat bild liegt
exklusiv der technische bericht der
guardia civil vom 8 juni 2022 vor unter
dem punkt 5.2 entzündungs quellen heißt
es wahrscheinlich produziert durch den
wurf eines brennbaren zuvor entzündeten
elements wie es eine zigarette oder
ähnliches sein kann vom kriminal labor
werden auch zwei steckdosen als mögliche
brandursachen untersucht doch die
scheiden aus im bericht heißt es dass
die krümmung und oxidation der
dachkonstruktion eher darauf schließen
ließen dass eine externe entzündungs
quelle auf die schill fransen gefallen
sei ob das feuer vorsätzlich oder
fahrlässig entstand konnte bislang nicht
geklärt werden kleiner hoffnungsschimmer
für die inhaftierten kegelbrüder die
individuelle verantwortung jedes
einzelnen der beschuldigten kann nicht
bestimmt werden da keine indizien
gefunden wurden die einen von ihnen
zuzurechnen wären weil alle acht
inhaftierten kegelbrüder auf dem balkon
waren von dem die kippe laut ermittlern
flug gibt es für sie keine
unschuldsvermutung
ein spanischer justizmitarbeiter zu bild
wer seine unschuld nicht bezeugt der
akzeptiert damit seine schuld oder
mitschuld wenn die kegler weiter
schweigen werden sie als mittäter oder
verschleiere eigentlich durch die
kegelbrüder selbst bestreiten die tat
nach wie vor augenzeugen jedoch belasten
die jungen männer schwer
ich habe gesehen wie junge männer auf
dem balkon standen und gefeiert haben es
wurde laute musik gespielt plötzlich
stand die terrasse in flammen
dieselbe augenzeugen die die jungen
männer gesehen haben will kann tage
später keinen der kegler identifiziert
ich habe ihre gesichter nicht richtig
gesehen hier kommt davon keiner
die augenzeugen ist sich jetzt sicher
die deutschen die durch ihre lautstärke
aufgefallen sind wohnten nicht in diesem
zimmer mit balkon von dem aus das feuer
ausgegangen sein soll
die jungs stand nicht auf den balkon
ganz außen sondern auf der zweiten und
dritten etage mit wenn man von
rechtsaußen anfängt zu zählen war es der
dritte balkon und der balkon darüber in
der dritten etage die aussage der zeugin
deckt sich mit den aussagen von familie
und verteidigung die 13 freunde wohnten
demnach nicht in dem zimmer des hotels
ihre zimmer befand sich vielmehr zehn
meter vom ausbruch des feuers entfärbt
auch dieses handy video widerspricht den
aussagen der spanischen justiz zwei
männer auf dem balkon während das feuer
lichterloh brennt zwei männer die nicht
eindeutig den kegelbrüdern zuzuordnen
sind keine markanten blauen t shirt wie
sie die brüder auf ihrem letzten
gemeinsamen foto tragen fakt ist die
kegelbrüder waren auf einem balkon des
nachbargebäudes fakt es auch die
kegelbrüder haben geraucht
und nun der brand bericht der guardia
civil mit dem ergebnis dass das feuer
von einer zigarettenkippe ausgelöst
worden ist kein guter tag für die acht
männer aus münster
ja kein guter tag bild reporter jörg
völkerling der diesen fall vor ort dort
in mallorca auch recherchiert hat ich
grüße dich kein guter tag im grunde der
nächste hoffnungsschimmer für die
kegelbrüder aus münster der durch dieses
gutachten jetzt dahin ist
ja das ist dieses gutachten was
inzwischen schon einen monat alt ist
andererseits war das brand labor doch
sehr schnell bei der sache schon nach
vier fünf wochen teilweise vier wenigen
tagen konnte man hier auf die
zigarettenkippen theorie den brand
zurückführen und damit auch die
staatsanwaltschaft letztlich bestätigen
auch der richter der die haftbefehle
erlassen hat wird sich jetzt bestätigt
sehen auch wenn dieses gerade mal zwei
seiten lange gutachten eigentlich nur
belegt ja ok zigaretten könnten die
ursache gewesen sein aber wir können die
schuld nicht individuell zu ordnen dass
steht definitiv drin man kann wieder
sagen ob das fahrlässig passiert ist
dass die zigaretten hinunter geworfen
wurden oder ob das mit dem vorsatz
geschah hier diese dieses schiff dach in
brand zu setzen man muss sich
vergegenwärtigen
wir haben es hier mit leuten zu tun die
in der freiwilligen feuerwehr aktiv sind
die sehr wohl wissen was vorher
anrichten kann natürlich war es ein sehr
heißer maitag bis zu 38 grad es ging ein
wind andererseits erinnere ich mich gut
an die erste begegnung mit dem
verteidiger der kegelbrüder der mir in
palma abends vor allem hotel
demonstriert hat ein hochprozentiger
wodka in der hand und seine zigarre in
der anderen er ließ asche hineinfallen
und die ist einfach ausgegangen da ist
nichts passiert und hier wurde er
behauptet dass sie sozusagen alkohol
bier hin und zugeschüttet hätten und
dass das noch als brandbeschleuniger
zusätzlich gewirkt hätte also das ist
ziemlich weit hergeholt andererseits
haben wir jetzt auch diesen google
rechtsgutachter diesen rechtsanwalt
gehört die unschuldsvermutung ist in
spanien offenbar ins gegenteil verkehrt
wenn die anwesenheit dieser acht noch in
u-haft sitzenden kegelbrüder am tatort
belegt ist muss jeder einzelne seine
unschuld beweisen
also einer müsste jetzt aussagen wer es
war und dann könnte er das freikommen ja
aber das ist ja durchaus ein seltsames
verfahren wenn die kegelbrüder die dann
noch einen sitzen erstmal beweisen
müssen dass sie die zigarette nicht
geworfen haben das erscheint ja völlig
unmöglich also wer setzt sich jetzt
eigentlich für die jungs dort im alle
knast noch ein
da gehen jetzt diverse schriftsätze hin
und her es ist natürlich auch das ganze
gefahren dieses untersuchungsrichters
über das wir gestern schon gesprochen
haben mehr als fragwürdig das wirkt ein
bisschen wie auf einem basar dieses hin-
und herschieben von einer halben million
euro als so die da hatte obwohl es
eigentlich nur ein schaden von 150.000
euro ist dann wiederum auf welchem
konnte wird das eingezahlt fünf sind ja
frei einer ohne auflagen weil er zum
tatzeitpunkt duschen war die anderen
vier sind frei weil sie abgewandte nicht
zur straße nicht so bei weinort mallorca
zeigende zimmer hatten mussten aber
12.000 euro zahlen also ich glaube dass
letztlich ist der fall ja auch bei der
nächst höheren instanz um einfach dieses
ganze gebaren und vorgehen des
ermittlungsrichters zu hinterfragen und
ich denke auch dass hier unabhängige
gutachter noch eingeschaltet werden die
diese zigarettenkippen theorie der
guardia civil erschüttern sollen das ist
hier wie auf dem basar sagt bild
reporter jörg völkerling danke dir
und direkt weiter zu anwalt an kempkens
der von beginn an diesen fall der 13
kegelbrüder aus münster hier mit bild
verfolgt hat ich grüße sie herzlich
champions ich würde gerne mit drei
schnellen fragen beginnen nämlich mit
denen die mich umtreiben also glauben
sie nach all dem was sie jetzt auch aus
dem gutachten wissen dass eine
zigarettenkippe die ursache sein kann
dass eine ganze bar abfackelt
möglich aber ich glaube eher
unwahrscheinlich glauben sie dass das
vorsatz sein kann
durchaus möglich aber ebenfalls eher
unwahrscheinlich und dritte frage
glauben sie jetzt dass man denen einen
ausmachen wird herausfinden kann der
diese entscheidende zigarettenkippe
möglicherweise in diese bar geworfen hat
halte ich für technisch völlig
ausgeschlossen also das heißt sie haben
auch zweifel an der geschichte die
dieses gutachten jetzt erzählte kempkens
ja also es ist wahrscheinlich möglich
dass man nachweisen kann das ist
tatsächlich durch zigaretten passiert
ist ist eine möglichkeit aber wir müssen
ja im strafrecht sozusagen 100 prozent
haben und ich habe zweifel ob man diese
100 prozent erreicht ob das überhaupt
diese eine zu heute war und dann stellt
sich natürlich die frage wer hat sie
konkret geworfen es scheint ja in diesem
fall aber umgekehrt zu sein offenbar
müssen die kegelbrüder zumindest die
acht die weiterhin da im knast ausharren
nach 49 tagen 100 prozent beweisen dass
sie es nicht waren sowie das wirkt
halte ich für strafrechtliche völlig
verfehlt denn es ist ja nicht etwa so
nur weil da ein paar leute zusammen
gestanden haben und dann hat einer oder
zwei oder drei rundfunk gemacht dann
heißt das ja nicht dass alle dafür
strafrechtlich mithaften das ist im
gegenteil so nicht die täter müssen sich
entlassen sondern es gilt die
unschuldsvermutung man muss ganz konkret
sagen welcher täter dabei war und
welcher sich möglicherweise dann
sukzessive wäre das ein anderer
vielleicht damit angefangen hat
bescheinigt hat dann haben wir
gemeinsamen tatplan und nur dann sind
mehrere strafbar einmal ganz deutlich
gefragt diese acht kegelbrüder sässen
die in deutschland aller voraussicht
nach auch nach 49 tagen immer noch
gemeinsam im knast auf keinen fall danke
für die klaren aussagen bei bild am
abend danke an den bürgern kenntnis ja
also das ist ein justiz krimi und durch
das neue ermittler gutachten wird jetzt
noch enger für die kegelbrüder aus
münster seit ewig langen 49 tagen eben
im knast und wenn sie mal kennen dann
kennen sie auch diesen knast er ist
nämlich direkt am flughafen schwer zu
übersehen und wir schauen mit ihnen
einmal rein in dieses gefängnis von
palma
der knast von palma de mallorca hier
sitzen die kegelbrüder aus dem
münsterland seit drei wochen ein es sind
die ersten bilder die uns einblick
gewähren hinter die mauern des
gefängnisses ein geistlicher der sich um
die deutschen kümmert schildert
besorgniserregendes der titel ist einer
der fahrer einer der seelsorger der die
jetzt acht verbliebenen kegelbrüder hier
im gefängnis betreut und was er
berichtet das klingt wenig optimistisch
es ist ja auch wenn es einer der
modernsten knäste ist doch von den
insassen her ein gefängnis das nicht
ohne ist und einsatz der wirklich sehr
betroffen macht sie weinen heimlich in
ihre kissen rückblick am zwanzigsten mal
fliegen die kegelbrüder aus nordrhein
westfalen nach mallorca wollen ein
fröhliches wochenende verbringen nachdem
sie in ihr hotel eingecheckt haben
geschieht die tragödie in einer
benachbarten bar bricht ein feuer aus
weil sie zu diesem zeitpunkt auf ihrem
hotelbalkon ganz in der nähe geraucht
hatten geraten die deutschen unter
verdacht werden kurze zeit später
festgenommen
einer der 13 ist offenbar in barfuß
sozusagen abgeführt worden und dann dem
richter vorgeführt wurden und so ist
eigentlich neben der seelsorge die die
fahrer hier leisten können eines der
wichtigsten dinge die sie in den knast
transportieren können so etwas banales
wie socken unterwäsche
inzwischen gibt es vermutungen dass
versicherungsbetrug im spiel sein könnte
einer der kegelbrüder aber gleich in den
ersten tagen freigekommen nachdem er
beweisen konnte dass er zum fraglichen
zeitpunkt duschen war vor drei tagen
waren vier weitere männer freigelassen
worden 12.000 euro kaution hatten sie
zuvor zahlen müssen sie sind schon
wieder in deutschland konnten von ihren
familien in die arme geschlossen werden
aber der abschied von ihren 13 von ihren
acht verbliebenen freundin die sie schon
seit schultagen kennen dürfte ihnen sehr
schwergefallen sein wie es mit den acht
verbliebenen jetzt weitergeht steht
vollkommen in den sternen der richter am
untersuchungsgericht palmer hat ihnen ja
keine entlastungsmöglichkeit auf kaution
in aussicht gestellt und auch wenn das
gefängnis von mallorca zu einem der
modernsten europas gehört mit
swimmingpool sporthalle fitnessstudio
und bibliothek es bleibt ein knast in
dem die zellentür die meiste zeit zu
gesperrt ist acht männer in
gefangenschaft ihn möglicherweise
unschuldig sind denn das ist etwas was
der fahrer auch immer wieder
widerspiegelt den jungen leuten denen er
da begegnet das ist das entspricht so
gar nicht dem bild der deutschen auf
touristen das seien die vernünftige
junge männer und bild erfuhr auch aus
dem umkreis der familie was die jungen
leute zwischen 21 und 44 ihren familien
auch mitgeteilt haben dass selbst die
werte zu ihnen sagen ihr gehört hier
nicht hin und trotzdem das schicksal der
acht deutschen im knast von mallorca im
moment scheint es weiterhin völlig
ungewiss
[Musik]